[Music]
it's getting much worse I think it's
about the same I think it's gotten worse
it's most likely growing I think it's
getting worse because uh it's a lot of
people suffering I think in the
universities it's gotten worse there's a
confusion between anti-Semitism and
anti-israeli and they're confusing
confusing the two uh yeah there's been
an increase in
anti-israel thing which has been
interpreted as anti-Semitism I don't
believe in that you know I think
everybody should be treated equally no
matter where they are where they from or
what e the group they come from everyone
should be treated equally I don't think
no life is no better than any other life
there's no middle ground in more and
that's just sad I feel like it's the
swing has gotten deeper and further and
it's just gotten much worse for me
personally in my day-to-day it's not
something that is necessarily affecting
me but of course I mean I watch the news
I see things on social media that of
course is is scary to see um so yeah I
mean in terms of that um it's a little
bit more heightened than I think of
recent for sure racism people treating
people terribly um a lot of oh God it's
a whole lot of stuff going on it's sad
cuz uh hesman is is a negative uh
environment and nobody shouldn't want to
be in that type of envirment it's rather
shocking actually how how many people
side
with with anti-Semitism and just hating
people I mean it's so easy for us just
to love and get along all of us want
that all of us want to be included and
loved